well I'm joined Now by Michaela Peterson
Michaela lovely to see you and so I
interviewed your dad Jordan Peterson
let's get that out of the way quickly
was it like being Jordan Peterson's
daughter starting
well it's opened a lot of doors I think
that wouldn't have been opened me so
that's one thing
um it's extremely dramatic it's quite
stressful they're like ever since he
went viral in in 2017 our lives have
just been turned completely upside down
so like I was reading an article earlier
about how Jordan gets on TV and cries
about being famous
and I used to look at Celebrities and
think oh they're complaining about Fame
what are they complaining about you
having money on opportunity like stop it
but the amount of stress that also comes
with that I think is hard to understand
unless you experience it had a huge
impact on him on your family on you or
everyone right yeah yeah it's been wild
but I can't complain about the
opportunity I mean I've taken advantage
of that as much as I can well you become
a big star yourself you know when I tell
people I'm interviewing you young people
like oh wow that's great you know you've
got nearly a million subscribers to your
YouTube channel you're doing these huge
numbers on social media what is it about
you it's not just because you're
Jordan's daughter there's something else
what is it you think there's really
grabbing people's attention well I'm I
hope I hope that I'm telling the truth I
don't really care what people think of
me and I think my health story also
influenced a lot of people because
there's so many chronically ill people
and so I brought a lot of people into
the personal aspect of that and then I'm
I guess I'm a fairly disagreeable female
which I think is attractive to some
people but I would find that quite
agreeable
I'm polite but and that depends we might
agree on a lot of things so that might
be it we'd probably agree with more than
you think
um just for those who don't know your
health story very quickly tell me what
happened
I had juvenile rheumatoid arthritis
since I was two I was diagnosed when I
was seven and then my health just went
downhill so I was depressed I had
chronic fatigue my skin was a mess I was
on like eight medications and I couldn't
function I couldn't get out of bed and
when I was 22 I decided the medical
system wasn't helping me I'd had my hip
and Ankle replaced like I had years of
being on painkillers and things and so I
took it into my own hands and that was
when I was when I was 22 when I realized
that if you have issues in your life
nobody other than you is going to fix
them and I used to go to the medical
community because that's what I learned
to get help and that wasn't working for
me so I started to delve into diet I
went back to school for biomedical
degree which I didn't end up finishing I
did a couple of years of that and I
started delving around in diet so like
long story short I ended up only eating
meat which I think is also kind of what
helped people start following me because
they're like What's this weird all beef
woman do that fool I'm still on it so
you literally only six years you only
eat meat still yep
told me through a day's diet then uh
Stripling Stripling steak you wake up in
the morning what do you have for
breakfast strip wine what do you have
for lunch
what do you have for dinner sometimes
strip loin in soup and dinner same yeah
so you're three steaks a day yeah yeah I
would change it I would change it if I
could but uh as soon as I add anything
back in like there's still some
underlying crazy autoimmune problems
anytime I add anything back in you have
no vegetables or anything you just nope
nothing just a steak Yeah
do you have any Souls no I mean it's
kind of fascinating how long have you
done this six years yeah six years in
December you look like you're bursting
with good health I mean what are what
are the experts say about this uh
depends on the experts but mostly you
know you should have died by now is
usually the reaction I get
but do you oddly feel healthier than
you've ever felt
oh my gosh as a teenager I told you I
couldn't get out of bed yeah and I had
my hip and Ankle replaced I couldn't
walk so I mean my Baseline was nearly
dead right so compared to that I I feel
great do you like steak or you're not
sick of it if I had to live off of only
one food it would be New York strip loin
so at least there's that right if you go
to a restaurant you just have steak Yeah
just with salt this whistle just whistle
yeah I mean I love a steak with salt but
three times a day every day seven days a
week the alternative is worse
so that's why you drink alcohol I do
sometimes that puts a bit of a skew on
on the diet because they're like oh
you're you can only eat meat but you can
have some vodka but uh vodka doesn't
seem to give me arthritis so funny yeah
Bear Grylls the Explorer he was a he
tried veganism for a while then
renounced it all now feels ashamed by it
and he's gone pretty well full on meat
as well I noticed meat and vodka that's
probably you'd have to it's given the
things that he does yeah um so that's
the story and that's what really
electrified people's interest in you but
since then your opinions have also
become things that people are following
yeah how would you categorize yourself
in terms of your position for example on
things like masculinity where do you sit
with that because I know what your dad
does I've interviewed him obviously um I
don't think I'm quite as conservative as
my dad but I'm pretty conservative
compared to the average person
this whole trans debacle is really
pushing me into I don't know what like a
form of feminism or something just like
it's so insane yes like I feel like I
need to protect women even though it
it's made basically women causing this
but uh I don't know view on masculinity
I think men are having a harder time
which is why people like Andrew Tate
popped up and people like my dad
um and there's no I mean when I walk
around having interviewed both Jordan
Peterson and Andrew T the number of
young boys like late teens early 20s
that come up to about those interviews
months and months sometimes a year later
I'm wanting to talk about uh really
curious what I thought of them and what
I feel about that it showed me there's a
lot of young men who were wandering
around kind of aimlessly and wanting
Direction and they feel with your dad
and with Andrew Tate and these others
that they feel like at least somebody is
trying to understand them and to guide
them yeah I'm I'm so incredibly grateful
for my dad I don't know if I would have
been able to figure out my health
problems if I hadn't had him as a father
because he basically told me I needed to
fix my life I couldn't use my health as
an excuse even though it was a
legitimate excuse and I think people
aren't told how to make plans with their
lives like hey what's the goal you want
to achieve what are the steps you need
to follow in order to get there just
something as simple as that and so I
know people like my dad tell people how
to do that and it changes their lives
because there they go they have a plan
and then
why are so many young people anxious
what is this anxiety epidemic about do
you think is it dopamine from the
constant sensory overload of stuff they
see on their phones or what is it well I
think it's multifaceted I mean the
political atmosphere is a disaster what
you're being taught in in schools of
disaster social media seems to be a
disaster so that's got to play a role
and then there's no gender anymore for
any of these kids in school that's got
to be mentally confusing and then I I
mean I think there's a Health crisis in
America I think I was one of the people
that got hit by that so I know that the
Health crisis is impacting people some
will be exacerbated by the covert
pandemic oh my gosh yes it's separated
people it created a lot of loneliness a
lot of people it made it worse right
yeah definitely yeah covid was a
disaster especially in Toronto massive
problems there right but do young people
also have they developed a kind of
inability to to deal with normal life
stuff I mean I sense that there is a
problem there it just getting through
day-to-day normal life a lot of you
young people are struggling why
I don't think that they think they have
control over anything I didn't think
they're taught in school that they don't
have control over the government they
don't have control over their lives so
if they're dealt a bad hand of cards
then there's nothing they can do about
it and then they get resentful and
hopeless which is why people like my dad
I think have gotten famous because it's
like no you do have the power to change
your life you just need to make a plan
and you have to stick to that plan you
have to work on it so I think I think
it's people feeling lack of control over
their Destiny you know they've got
emotional with me he cried quite openly
talking about the Lost men really of our
generation is he very emotional at home
when you he is exactly the same person
camera as he is at home yeah yeah
exactly the same I mean it must be in a
way it must be quite exhausting but also
incredibly intellectually stimulating to
be around someone like him uh yeah I
mean we got taught about the
the psychological significance of the
Bible when I was like seven so that that
was like dinner table talk I had no idea
that my dad was weird until I was like
24.
you see until I met him I thought he
would maybe weird or very controversial
or whatever I wasn't quite sure what I
was going to meet and when I met him I
didn't think any of those things I
thought he was unbelievably bright he
really thought through these issues he'd
obviously been massively misunderstood
or deliberately mischaracterized and I
felt like everyone think he's a Force
for good if people actually listen to
what he says
if they listen to what he says yeah but
people like sound bites they're so much
easier to digest yeah yeah for the
Peterson Clan then what is life like now
I mean you've come to this Maelstrom of
years of chaos and attention and fame
and so on where have you washed up
we're still kind of in the middle of it
but I think we're more emotionally
resilient so when articles used to come
out about my dad they used to hit him
really hard like a New York Times
article would come out somebody who
would come into our house pretend to be
all friendly and then boom this negative
article that was really hard every
single time that happened it was a
catastrophe and now we're not phased at
all he's not phased at all so we've
gotten used to it that way but I don't
think the controversy stopped like where
there's definitely more people this is
one thing that's weird that happens when
you have money is people come after you
I didn't realize I'd heard about that I
didn't realize that happened so we're
dealing with that in like four different
ways
you mentioned politics earlier I mean
what are your gonna vote for
obviously are you still a Canadian
citizen or oh yeah so right so you don't
even we wouldn't vote for true though
right oh absolutely not being so screwed
yeah I know I moved I moved out of
Canada I moved out of Canada in 2021
because the downtown Toronto had been
destroyed and I thought there's no way
this isn't getting significantly worse
and it is worse like back this summer
it's much worse so yeah Trudeau is
definitely no Canada's screwed I think
for the next 10 years what do you think
of the likes of Megan and Harry who
positioned themselves as the priests and
High Priestess of of wokory
I pretty much ignore those two
uh what do I think of them
I don't think they're particularly
bright and they're very famous and so
and hugely privileged whilst moaning
about their lives all the time
sometimes they give a flies with the
regular public right yeah precisely what
are the things when you get up in the
morning and you've had your steak and
I'm looking forward to your next steak
um when you get out there what are the
things that really exercise you what do
you care most passionately about
well my dad and I and we have a team
well we've been working on a project
called Peterson Academy which is
launching in November
I think that's probably my passion right
now I've also really at his Essence
what's it about well uh I I went to
University I took four years I took two
half degrees and it was woke in 2012 and
so I was paying for courses that were
taught through a feminist perspective
and it really pissed me off and I know
that the average University degree Now
in America costs students between a
hundred and two hundred thousand dollars
and it teaches them to hate their
country that they have no control over
their lives and doesn't set them up for
jobs and so we thought hey we have
access to the top professors across the
world
let's grab those let's film really high
quality like Netflix like lectures and
let's give people access to a degree for
thirty dollars a month just flatten the
education system so we're hoping to
reduce the price of a University degree
by offering a general education degree
that teaches people
how to think and how to have
intellectual conversations with anybody
so like history politics we have we even
have a course on like how to address
well to be taken seriously yeah just
something that I hope everybody can
access and as you do as your dad does
he's always Immaculate as well I learned
from the best you look small you dress
smart I think you all you behave small I
think thank you it's yes my mother
always told me to dress as if I'm about
to meet the queen which was handy
because then I eventually did
that's why I always wear a suit you
never know when when the Monarch may
call yeah no precisely you're taking
more seriously why wouldn't anybody do
it it's the life hack
what's your message to women who don't
want to put their head over the parabit
about this gender stuff because it seems
to be a lot of women get shot down and
they're all terrified as speaking up for
women
I'd they'd be happier if they spoke up
for women I mean you can't not say
things it's not like those ideas go away
in your head right even if you're
worried about what your brain is telling
you they don't go away the ideas are
still there so I learned that the hard
way there were a couple years when I got
anxious and I didn't say what I was
thinking and I mean it drove me crazy so
say what you think it'll make you feel
better and the repercussions for telling
the truth are never worse than lying
ever even if it takes a couple years to
catch up to you they're never worse
because it's great to talk to you thank
you so much for having me on it's great
to see you send your father my very best
I will and I'll look forward to the
academy it sounds fascinating I might
even enroll myself thank you good to see
you